they're not vaccines and that you know I
don't know if you're familiar with the
right to die cases that came out of
Oregon and and uh
um
Washington governor governor Booth
Gardner if I'm not mistaken was integral
to that fight
right and and the outcome in the Supreme
Court was ultimately that you could not
you could not force someone to take a
treatment even if it were life-saving in
other words Supreme Court said we don't
even belong here you know but you cannot
force someone to take a life-saving
treatment and so if these these vaccines
that aren't if it turns out they're a
treatment legally speaking that means
that even if you are even if you could
show that they saved a life and I'm with
you I don't believe that's been shown in
fact I know it hasn't uh you know that's
a different issue but
um that you can't mandate a life-saving
therapy on someone under Supreme Court
precedence so if these are if these are
Gene therapies then you're you know
you've taken paternalism to a level now
we the the underlying premise would be
the government can controls your body
and you're getting your immune system on
a license agreement
thank you
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast this is going to be a very
special episode I have the distinct
pleasure and honor of sitting today with
John Bose Dale Saran and Olivia Degen
Kolb I'm going to allow them to tell you
who they are and what role they play and
to deliver a disclaimer that I know they
must in order to protect themselves from
uh forces that would rather that they
not show up and speak publicly about
what they have seen why don't we start
with you John
well thank you for having me on Brad
it's really a privilege to be here and
an honor my name is John Bose I'm a
first lieutenant in the United States
Air Force and I'm an F-16 student pilot
who was grounded over the covid-19
vaccine mandates and I want to make it
clear that like Brett said I do have a
disclaimer and that is that I'm
representing myself and my thoughts and
opinions expressed here are purely my
own and I don't represent the Department
of Defense or the United States Air
Force
all right Dale
my name is Dale Saran I'm an attorney
I'm a retired Marine major I don't need
any disclaimers because the Marine Corps
doesn't pay my salary anymore but my
opinions are my own as always
and Olivia
Olivia degenkolb active duty naval
officer for 20 years now as John
mentioned the thoughts and opinions are
my own I do not represent the Department
of Defense or the department of the Navy
excellent so what brings us together is
a shared battle over
vaccine mandates they're not the only
mandates but they're clearly the central
ones here and I think what many
Americans and many in the west do not
understand is that although mandates
have largely been lifted across much of
the civilian World they are still quite
active in the military now I don't know
the full details of that I'm aware that
courts have enjoined mandates in certain
branches of the Armed Forces and not in
others before we get to the details of
that and the details of what you each
have experienced what follows is a very
special episode of Dark Horse it's the
first in a series in which I talk to
military whistleblowers about the
mandates that they still face they are
bold for coming forward and this kind of
programming is only possible because we
have equally bold sponsors we're
grateful to them and we hope that you
will consider supporting them as well
our first Brave sponsor for this episode
is bubs Naturals Bub's natural sells
three products that are becoming ever
more popular in Fitness and outdoor
exploration circles collagen protein MCT
oil and apple cider vinegar gummies
many companies are selling similar
products but bubs is different here's
how
the products themselves are of the
highest quality carefully and
sustainably sourced and bubs is a
company with a conscience
bubs is named for former Navy SEAL Glenn
bub Doherty who was great friends with
people from all walks of life including
one of the founders of Bub's Naturals
for 364 days a year 10 of all profits go
to charities in Glenn's honor and on
Veterans Day that number is a hundred
percent
bubs Naturals encapsulates Glenn's
enthusiasm for life self-improvement and
helping others with the motto feel great
do good
try Bub's natural collagen protein which
is truly unflavored and soluble unlike
some of the collagen available from
other sources it's got just one
ingredient which is critical to joint
and gut health and Muscle Recovery and
you can add it to anything a glass of
water a smoothie a cup of coffee
and Bub's Naturals collagen protein is
sustainably sourced from grass-fed and
pasture-raised cows in southern Brazil
very far from the Amazon
and the MCT oil powder dissolves fast in
coffee for instance providing a healthy
sustained mental boost
the collagen protein and MCT oil are
very easy to add to any drink and help
with both mental focus and muscle and
joint wellness and Recovery
and the apple cider vinegar gummies are
in a word irresistible
bubs Naturals aspires to these words die
young as late as possible
go to bubsnaturals.com Darkhorse for
twenty percent off your order that's
b-u-b-s-n-a-t-u-r-a-l-s.com slash
Darkhorse
our second courageous sponsor is
American Hartford gold inflation is at
its highest level in 40 years we all
feel it at the grocery store and the
fuel pump interest rates are soaring
retirement accounts are in real Danger
if you want to protect your family's
financial future you should consider
that people have been putting wealth
into precious metals for thousands of
years
the more uncertain access to other
stores of value gets the more precious
precious metals are likely to become
call American Hartford gold to see how
easy it is to get started
they can show you how to protect your
savings and retirement accounts by
diversifying your portfolio with
physical gold and silver composed of
actual atoms rather than zeros
all it takes to get started is a short
phone call and they'll have physical
gold and silver delivered right to your
door or inside your IRA or 401k
they are the highest rated firm in the
country with an A plus rating from the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients
call them now they will give you a
percentage of your first qualifying
order back in free silver
call American Hartford gold at
866-828-1117 that's
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse to 998899
again that's
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse to
998899 our final Fearless sponsor is
eight sleep
sleep is necessary and good sleep is a
game changer without good sleep we are
condemned to be less healthy and less
productive
but despite the importance of good sleep
more than 30 percent of Americans
struggle to get it and temperature is
one of the main reasons
it is well known that individuals in
couples who sleep together often have
different optimal sleep temperatures
eight sleep allows fine-tuned
temperature regulation for both people
having a cool room and a warm bed is a
luxury that H sleep makes easy to obtain
or a warm room with a cool bed
you schedule your temperature
preferences for your side of the bed in
advance and if you want to tweak it
during the night that's easy too
the Pod Pro cover by H sleep is the most
advanced Solution on the market for
thermal regulation you can add the cover
to any mattress and start sleeping as
cool as 55 degrees Fahrenheit or as hot
as 110.
the temperature of the cover adjusts
each side of the bed based on sleep
stages Biometrics and bedroom
temperature dynamically creating the
optimal sleep environment for you
eight sleep users fall asleep 32 percent
faster and reduce sleep interruptions by
40 percent and they get more restful
sleep overall
and with 30 percent more deep
restorative sleep on average they are
likely to benefit from faster physical
recovery improved hormone regulation and
increased mental clarity
finally the wake up feature which can
signal you with temperature change and
or slight chest level vibrations isn't
jarring at all it's much gentler than
any standard alarm
Heather and I were both skeptical about
the value of a technologically enhanced
mattress but we are now totally
convinced we are surprised at how much
we appreciate this bed when we are home
and how much we miss it when we are away
go to hsleep.com Darkhorse to check out
the Pod Pro cover and save 150 bucks at
checkout eight sleep ships to the U.S
Canada and the UK that's eightsleep.com
Darkhorse
I did want to say a word about why Dale
is here
Dale is functioning as an attorney in
this context and he brings not only
experience with the law but experience
with past military mandates over
vaccines as I understand it Anthrax
being Central in in that earlier fight
and so that battle over the anthrax
vaccine actually sheds a great deal of
light on the current battle over the
covid-19 vaccines that most of us are
just simply unaware of so Dale I'm glad
to have you here to provide that context
and also to provide Insight on the
various nuances of the law that
obviously surround the question of
whether mandates are legitimate
um do you want to say something about
the anthrax battle how it ended up where
it stands now
I think it's and thank you uh Brett for
having me on yeah this is a had been a
these mandates I think it's important
just for a little historical context to
kind of understand how we got here
is that the the anthrax vaccine was
really uh well first of all it was the
first eua vaccine so now everybody knows
what eua means emergency use authorized
product but
um uh the first one of those was
actually the anthrax vaccine back in
2004 but all of this really begins
um uh at least in the recent history in
with the Gulf War
and the dod you know I don't need to
tell you about the wmds and and we
probably don't need to to cover that
history too much but the dod's view was
that
um it should have the authority to
inject uh military members with
prophylaxis uh vaccines give them drugs
a whole bunch of stuff
and that really began in the Gulf War
and everything that's happened since
then has just been a a really a
continuous March and it happens to track
my career I was commissioned in 1991 as
an officer and I didn't really know
about it but the Gulf War vets that I
you know some of the guys I flew with
certainly had stories about you know
these uh variety of products but Gulf
War Illness which I think you know those
of us old enough to remember that are
familiar with out of the 700 000 or so
uh service members who served in Gulf
War One the Persian Gulf War about a
hundred thousand reported some kind of
symptoms that that came to be known as
Gulf War syndrome
and that really led to
um eventually to the eua statute and all
of this but prohibitions on the
department of defenses use of unlicensed
products uh in operations to protect
service members and where we are now is
really just the the end state of that of
that march to be honest with you
um well there's a lot I want to know
about that I followed for quite some
time the the story of Gulf War syndrome
I was absolutely struck by
I guess I probably would not at the time
have called it gaslighting but I
certainly would now the idea that many
people who served in Iraq were suffering
from a recognizable syndrome and
um the military and and the federal
government was simply pretending that it
was in their heads and
um that shocked me I remember
um as a scientifically minded person
thinking very carefully about what might
have caused the syndrome
uh at the point that I I stopped paying
attention to the story I thought the
leading hypothesis was depleted uranium
rounds which were strewn around the
battlefield and
um my understanding now is that that
probably was not uh the the cause and
that in fact there was reason to suspect
the anthrax vaccine which was
experimental I'm learning from you now
it was literally the first emergency use
authorized uh medical product
it sure was it was the first one granted
that status but that that came later in
the context of the litigation over the
legality of that program in in 2003. I
was a young Judge Advocate in 99 I've
been a pilot and then uh left that uh
got into a program that that turned me
into a lawyer a military lawyer and
um that uh my first case is among my
first cases in Okinawa Japan were about
a dozen or so uh Marines and a sailor
who would refuse the anthrax vaccine
and I think uh having been a prior
military officer I assumed because my
command sort of put in my head that
these guys were just malcontents and you
know non-hackers and they didn't they
they were just looking for an excuse
these were people who were otherwise
this was their out and
um uh I quickly was disabused of that
notion uh after talking to my clients
and some of the folks they were involved
with I found out quite quickly that that
the program was illegal that it was an
illegal order which is kind of a strange
thing to stumble onto as a brand new
lawyer
a strange thing indeed and I must say
um
I'm heartened to see people like all
three of you fighting this battle I feel
that it is a battle that I'm fighting
and I'm meeting Patriots of every
conceivable stripe who have all realized
that something very serious as afoot and
I think the the quickest route to that
recognition is the idea that we are
looking at orders that any reasonable
person can determine are immoral and the
fact is immoral orders have a special
status for me that status is codified by
Nuremberg and the idea that the world in
the aftermath of the Holocaust and World
War II it
spent a great deal of effort figuring
out what one was supposed to do at the
point they had been ordered to do
something obviously immoral and the
answer is you are supposed to reject the
order so this is a a matter that stands
above the chain of command in fact it is
a check on the chain of command now
um the modern context is clearly very
different but any time Nuremberg is in
play I believe it's an all hands on deck
moment right if if Nuremberg is in
Jeopardy if we're going to forget those
lessons then we are in danger of a new
tragedy of History which undoubtedly
will not look like any of the previous
versions but we we simply do not want to
allow we cannot allow anything to be
added to the list of great tragedies and
this is our warning sign so
um interesting that you as a young
lawyer encountered immoral orders and
that must have been
um quite bewildering to be dealing with
you know effectively the top legal
concern at the early part of your career
yeah and I think the other interesting
thing was that the research quickly led
me to conclude that um and this this may
this may bum you out in the aftermath of
Nuremberg
um but it's been a this has been
constant
um non-stop for for all that we
prosecuted the folks at Nuremberg
um you know there was uh three of the
charges against some of the doctors were
dropped they actually uh were able to
defend themselves on some of the charges
um the idea is that Nuremberg was based
on the idea of international common law
and so the the Allied Forces were
Prosecuting the Germans and said this
was clearly outside the pale beyond the
pale and some of the German doctors were
like wait a minute you guys have been
doing this
the whole time there is no International
common law you know the British have
been doing this at Port and down you've
been experimenting on your own troops
and of course we had been flashing we
had been doing uh you know there were
the atomic veterans and then of course
you fast forward into Korea and post you
know 52 to 64 I think was the MK Ultra
programs a joint Army CIA you know get
unwittingly giving them
um uh LA hallucigens and
um there was a senate report done during
the Gulf War
um
when Congress really got involved and
started holding some hearings in the mid
90s there's a senate print
103-97 and it's called the Rockefeller
report named for the senator but it's
it's called something like 50 years of
you know uh 50 years of experiments on
Veterans or something like that and it
was a look and it had testimony from all
these World War II veterans who had who
had been
um uh silenced and that's part of the
problem with the military isn't John and
Olivia can certainly talk to this is you
know the military can make you sign
documents classify things and say you
can't talk about this and so the very
people who are being
harmed and having you know what amounts
to war crimes conducted on them uh the
man break tests with mustard gas I mean
there's Terrible Things documented in
there but that's been Non-Stop and you
can take that right through Agent Orange
um you know all the way up through then
the Gulf War so so I hate to say it I
mean as much as we point to Nuremberg
and the U.S likes to point fingers at
other countries are our record of uh uh
you know living up to those ideals has
been
has been just about non-existent about
all right
um well I accept what you say and I know
uh a good deal about several of the
subjects you mentioned so I I would
agree that this is hardly the unique new
violation on the other hand there's
obviously something about the scale of
this violation that is I would argue
unprecedented because not only is it
being uh inflicted upon members of the
military it's being inflicted
simultaneously across the civilian
population and not just in the U.S
either this has been a global effort and
so
um something unprecedented is taking
place here but it we are uh wise to be
reminded of the long history of uh
explorations of uh how effective
Nuremberg really is as a as a policy so
let's um let's bring Olivia and John
into this Olivia do you want to start by
by telling us your story what's happened
to you and how it fits into the context
of your career in your life sure
absolutely so I went to boot camp right
after 9 11.
UM
obviously joined the military to support
and defend the Constitution I truly love
my country in the American way I always
prior enlisted selected for the semen to
Admiral program which is an enlisted
officer commissioning program was a
naval flight officer on e2s and
subsequently selected for uh Naval or
I'm sorry not Naval flight officer
foreign area officer which is
effectively international relations
I was an Olmsted scholar so studied in
Beijing for two years and was recently
selected as the assistant Naval attache
designate to Beijing I was supposed to
go to Beijing I actually went you know
did language training went through
training and you know briefed with
people just ensured that I was ready to
represent the United States abroad and
prior to the Department of Defense
mandates
being announced I was told hey we've
heard a rumor that there might be these
mandates coming and so we're going to
put you on operational hold you and your
family aren't allowed to go anywhere
at the time I had significant medical
concerns I had concerns both about
fertility if you read the
Pfizer or I guess the community package
insert it specifically addresses male
fertility carcinogenicity you know
genotoxicity
um it it states actually let me read
this to you it's just too funny it
states um this is Pfizer's uh package
insert it says in a developmental
toxicity study in rats with Community
there was no vaccine related effects on
female fertility end quote I don't know
about you but you know as someone
who is a firm believer in science by
backgrounds in nuclear engineering and
Engineering physics I am just not
comfortable
um putting the balance of my fertility
on a couple rats you know
so well you ain't kidding I am going to
restrain myself from uh discussing here
the particular issues with the rodents
that are used for these studies but let
me just say that when I was a graduate
student I'm an evolutionary biologist
when I was a graduate student I was
studying what I thought was just an
interesting evolutionary question which
is why do we grow feeble and inefficient
with age why do we uh seness and what I
stumbled onto was that we the way we
breed rodents for uh scientific tests
actually results in them becoming
extremely robust to toxic substances
and this is a problem that as far as I
know has never been corrected so the the
mice are in fact biased to make
dangerous substances look much safer
than they actually are so even if these
rats were excellent models you would be
right to be hesitant but given what
these mice and rats actually are your
hesitancy is uh much more than Justified
further I would say terrifying it is
terrifying and the fact that it has not
been addressed is is mind-boggling to me
I thought when I found this this uh
problem that science would rush to
correct it because it was blinding us it
was in fact causing us to believe things
were true that we're not because these
animals were misleading
um and when instead my colleagues simply
pretended the problem didn't exist it it
woke me up to um what has gone wrong in
uh in science in Academia in the
regulation of uh drug safety all of
these things but I would also say that
there is evidence
actually of the accumulation of lipid
nanoparticles in reproductive tissue in
rats also and so the whole idea that
what we've learned from rats tells us
that this would be safe for women's
fertility is nonsense there's reason to
wonder about its effect on fertility and
at best what we can say is we don't know
right which is not all that comforting
exactly
exactly so you know I had those concerns
I brought them up to my chain of command
and to my doctor the doctor kind of blew
me off and you know said hey this is a
non-issue
at the time there were a lot of people
seeking medical exemptions and you know
speaking to their doctors about concerns
they had with the MRNA vaccine
specifically and
so it took a while to get an appointment
and in that time frame I I learned that
you know it was illegal to mandate
emergency use authorized products and
that the vaccines that were available
that were being given not only to the US
military but to the American people were
all emergency use authorized products
so I started to notify my chain of
command
um
I actually wrote a point paper about my
concerns and sent it up to the Pentagon
back in October I I did everything I
could to you know kind of sound the
alarm and over time started meeting
other like-minded people who were
similarly situated you know also
unvaccinated and concerned I filed a
religious accommodation with the help of
a lot of those people I was learning you
know the process for a religious
accommodation along with everyone else I
think you know prior to that I'd known
one person who'd submitted a religious
accommodation in 20 years of service so
being able to talk to other people who
were also researching this topic was
incredibly helpful and you know as a
group over time we've just realized
more and more challenges that are
associated with these vaccines a their
emergency use authorized so you can't
mandate them under title 21 and for
military title 10 for religious
accommodations there seemed to be
blanket disapprovals within the service
which obviously you know is
unconstitutional
um for me when when the president
mandated or I guess not mandated but
pushed out executive order I believe was
14043 mandating civilians government
civilian employees to take the vaccine
that was honestly when for me I had a
real
real problem with um problem of
conscience it effectively said look you
know because of the successes we've had
with and I'm paraphrasing here you've
got to pull up the actual executive
order but because of the successes we've
had with mandating covet guidance in
agencies and at the time the dod the
military specifically was the only
agency that was mandating the covet
vaccine we are going to require this of
the civilian population at that point I
felt that the military's acquiescence to
taking these emergency use authorized
covid-19 vaccines had resulted in them
being rolled out on the civilian
population which was clearly
unconstitutional and that for me was a
huge crisis of conscience it was
terrifying and again it was actually the
basis of my religious accommodation
which under the religious freedom
restoration act most people don't know
this but you can file for religious
beliefs moral conscience or moral
principles and also your conscience so
that was
yeah just incredibly troubling and since
then
um there are you know over 80 000 other
service members that are in the same
situation that are looking at
potentially being kicked out many of us
have spoken to our leadership about our
concerns with the legality with the lack
of constitutionality
um you know with the Discrimination how
religious personnel and people with
medical issues are being
disproportionately impacted
and honestly they're falling on deaf
ears so you know whether whether we file
a religious accommodation or speak to
the chain of command or file an a equal
opportunity complaint or file an an
inspector general complaint most of
these aren't being resolved in a
satisfactory Manner and people have
given us answers from hey there's
nothing to see here two yes it looks
like there is a violation of law but
because it's currently being adjudicated
in courts there's nothing we can do so
we're going to continue to violate your
rights which obviously is unacceptable
so there are many uh themes in there I
want to make sure that we cover I do
want to ask you about the basis of the
religious objection I can think of
several
um but there are obviously important
questions here because religious
freedoms are uh called out specifically
in our Constitution and for good reason
I also want to talk about the
so for me there are certain things about
the story of the coveted treatments
um including these so-called vaccines
which really do not deserve that term
but nonetheless there's certain things
about the way this has transpired that
tell me that we are not dealing with a
normal story in which those who are
dictating policy are grappling with an
understandably difficult issue and
they're making some errors but
nonetheless they're doing the best they
can we know that's not the case because
among other things
we know that the risks of covid go
spectacularly down the younger you are
and the healthier you are and yet these
policies are persistently indifferent to
your own ability to fend off this
disease
which goes specifically then in the case
of the military mandates to questions of
readiness
which is the greater cost to Readiness
vaccinating healthy people and exposing
them to the risks of these experimental
treatments
sidelining people who have been trained
to do important jobs that are involved
in our Readiness because they have
reasons not to want to take these
so-called vaccines the fact that the
policy appears to be vaccinate at all
costs is inconsistent with the
military's Mission and I think obviously
so
um and you know I think your story uh
speaks to that
so I don't know which of those issues
you want to start with or uh
on the Readiness issue I think he's
really the one who's been tracking a
good deal of those numbers haven't you
John
yeah John you want to jump in I have
that's absolutely correct
yeah so the national security issue in
the Readiness issue is uh I think one of
the more serious ones that kind of
almost exists outside of the argument
about whether these vaccines are good or
bad or not and like like you've said
Brett is that uh it seems to be
inconsistent with the desire of the
military to have a competent ready force
and so uh just to paint a picture of
where we stand right now this year in
terms of Readiness it's not looking very
good the Army missed its recruiting goal
by 15 in this fiscal year 22 uh in the
Heritage Foundation recently came out
saying that the military's recruiting
this year fiscal year 22 is the worst
it's been since the all-volunteer force
began in 1973 and I'm sure you know
that's just after Vietnam the military
wasn't a very popular organization then
so our recruiting is really hurting in
the dmdc data which is the uh defense
Manpower data
Center has put out the numbers on on our
military total Force composition and if
you look at that data closely you
realize that people are leaving in Mass
after the vaccine mandates came down so
there's a case to say that it's almost
directly related to this and in April of
2022 we lost 10 000 people in a single
month total Uniform service Personnel in
the active Garden Reserve that's the
most people in a single month that we've
lost in over 10 years so people people
are running for the door already and
when you look at the fact that there are
80 000 plus unvaccinated service members
we already can't afford to lose anyone
and now we're saying that we want to
discharge 80 000 individuals because
they won't take a vaccine that our own
CDC says is meaningfully not important
anymore they've released guidance that
says the vaccinated unvaccinated should
be treated the same uh and so from that
perspective and especially these
tumultuous times this year uh I think
it's I think it's a dangerous policy to
adopt this idea that we need to get rid
of any person who doesn't want the
vaccine or we need to have 100
vaccination because from from a
Readiness perspective
um that's extremely detrimental to our
ability to defend our nation and perhaps
in 2020 when covid was still thought to
be extremely serious that maybe you
could make a case for that but now uh
with the data about vaccine injuries and
everything else
um there's there's I think absolutely no
case to say that we need to get rid of
these individuals or course them into
taking a vaccine that they don't want to
take because that's contrary to the
absolute Foundation of our country and
the Constitution and the foundation of
our military
yes you uh you point to a third uh ish
Readiness issue that I hadn't considered
which is that obviously bullying people
into taking these
the
um I know they're supposed to be safe
and effective but these obviously unsafe
and ineffective so-called vaccines
um is going to drive certain people who
might otherwise sign up to do something
else so we are taking highly competent
people like yourself and grounding them
after investing a great deal in training
you to to defend the country
we are driving people who might sign up
for such a job to to pick another
career and frankly the military's own
data on Adverse Events says that we're
injuring people who would otherwise have
been able to fight on our behalf so
that's three different ways that we are
harming Readiness here and the question
really is
why would we ever harm Readiness we
would need a very good reason to do that
given the fundamental role that the
military plays in keeping the Nation
free and making room for a society that
is frankly the fairest one that has ever
existed in and you know really I think
it it makes sense to think of
the founders of the United States as
having not only founded a great country
but having invented the West this is the
fairest system even if you like someone
else's version of it better it still
started here and defending it is
fundamental so the idea that something
is allowing us to [ __ ] our own
Readiness is another you know in
addition to Nuremberg sets off alarm
bells for me right is that even
well-intentioned or is has something
gotten into our system that is unhooking
our Readiness because it doesn't really
want us ready
a Brett you know there's an interesting
I I said when this first started I got a
lot of calls because people knew my
history with the issue but one of the
first things people ask me and included
people you know like John and Olivia and
a lot of military members particularly
Pilots uh and I've got some theories
about why that is but
um
uh people all asked me the same thing
they're like what like what is possibly
going on and it's related to what you
talked about with risk stratification
where
you know
um John for example is an F-16 pilot and
uh you know the idea that well coven's a
threat you know but
um John's on his own oxygen when he's
flying you know he's
right so the idea you know it's not like
he's got the air conditioner vents
turned up you know and this is It's So
the idea that like we've got to get all
these people who were at if you did by
risk stratification both by age health
and then by just the even Potential
Threat to them like in their day-to-day
workings as a pilot you know a lot of
the pilots that we have in this group
that you know live and John both no a
lot of the other folks in this group
um you know you're on your own oxygen
you're with I mean it's I don't know
like all of the possible justifications
for doing it are largely turn out to be
just nonsense and so you have to to your
point you have to start asking yourself
what what's really behind this and I
said that whether it was intentional or
not it perfectly uh split the force into
those who would bend the knee and those
who wouldn't and you know I don't know
what you could people control whatever
conclusions they want from that but but
that's in essence what the Mandate has
done
well I'll go one step further my
argument has been that there are two
violations of Nuremberg here one of them
is about informed consent and obviously
we are not well informed nor are we
being asked for our consent we are being
mandated uh to take these things and the
military uh is still being mandated even
when the rest of us have gotten a
reprieve but the other violation uh has
to do with the question of immoral
orders that we talked about earlier but
I would point out that if you have a
policy that delivers an immoral order
and then you fire the people who refuse
to take it you build a force that is
much more likely to accept immoral
orders in the future and the question is
I mean look at I think you said it very
carefully Dale and I agree with you I
freely admit I do not know what's going
on I do know that this looks like
something that is almost impossible to
explain Lane as a matter of incompetence
or being misinformed right we're in a
matter of incompetence or being
misinformed as the system woke up to
things like the adverse event signal the
policy would get better you would expect
there to be a lot of uh covering one's
ass and all of that but nonetheless the
policy would change in the direction of
reason we would stop mandating these
things for young healthy people for whom
the risk of the vaccine is actually
greater than the risk of covid and the
fact that that doesn't happen
um
what I've said before is that we have
been left with a policy that is actually
the it's not unreasonable it is the
inverse of a reasonable policy if you
did the opposite of what it asked you to
do you'd be far better off and it's hard
to explain that pattern by anything
other than some form of sabotage now
again am I alleging that there's a
saboteur
I don't know I I I'm not alleging it I
don't know that there is one but I do
know that the pattern matches what a
saboteur would do one thing a saboteur
would do is they would screw with our
Readiness another thing it would do is
it would try to make a compliant force
that didn't ask a lot of questions right
and so you know how many of these data
points do we need before we say look
we admit we don't know what's happening
but we do know it's um
it is tantamount to being attacked by an
adversary that does not have an interest
in our long-term well-being right it is
doing what that adversary would do maybe
there's no adversary but it is doing
what an adversary would do
yeah there's a point you know right
there's a point where
oh sorry
good
I was going to say there's a point in
the law where um you can arrive at the
functional equivalent of malice through
stupidity you know if you run me off the
road because you didn't you're
completely incompetent with your car I
it really
um to my family in my estate it won't
matter I'm dead either way and the only
difference will be what level of you
know uh criminal
incompetence we asked you know you can
be criminally incompetent you can be
criminally negligent you know so it at
some point stupidity can become the
functional equivalent of malice or
incompetence can be the functional
equivalent of malice and but I I'm with
you I don't I don't see incompetence
here because what I see is uh you know
now I'm in three three different cases
with this and I help on others but the
the Beast reacts and
even as the orders change to your point
Brett you know you're saying we would
see some competence we would think or
you would see some changes you see
what's really interesting is you see
some of the changes in print
but never is there a a retraction or or
or go back from the position in other
words the dod the CDC the FDA will put
things out that suggest yes we recognize
things are changing but nothing no
mandate stops it's almost it's it's
impossible for them to ever admit maybe
this was a bad idea well no I I'm going
to push back a little bit
if you imagined that you had incompetent
authorities
who were interested in our military
Readiness and thought that they were
serving that interest by mandating these
vaccines so that covet didn't render us
uh unprepared
then you would expect upon the discovery
that young people are better off fending
off the disease naturally than receiving
one of these vaccines which doesn't
prevent contraction doesn't prevent
transmission and carries its own risk
you would expect even if this cover
story was garbage you would expect a
shift in policy that would increase our
Readiness from the bad policy that was
delivered in the beginning the fact that
age stratification doesn't show up tells
us whatever it is is at the very least
completely indifferent to our readiness
or maybe it wants us on ready
what's your point on that Brett with
with
uh
the idea of you know I can't attest as a
service member to any sort of a
conspiracy or anything like that it's
it's not my place nor do I really know
with any certainty but uh at the very
least from the ground level up in most
leadership stratification all the way up
to the the general officer level
um you know I think the general centipin
is not so much this malice that exists
but more so of this is just how the
military works and to give you a little
background on myself I'm a fourth
generation military officer uh both my
parents were pilots in the United States
Air Force and so I grew up around
officers and I grew up around the
military environment and I I had a
passion for and I love it and I devoted
my life to becoming a fighter pilot and
a military officer and I was successful
in that and even at my time at the
Academy where you know they taught us
values of officership or uh you know
Integrity first service before self
excellence in all we do our oath to the
Constitution as officers all of these
values were instilled in me for my
entire life Nathan to a large degree for
pretty much every military officer and
so when I graduated from the academy as
a distinguished graduate I had high
hopes for how the military operated
based off my my life with my grandfather
and my mother and my father and with
what I saw at the Academy but it feels
like there's almost an inversion of
reality here where everyone talks about
these these high and beautiful values
that everyone aspires to have but then
an execution almost everyone says well
that's just how the military works you
know we follow orders and and you know
we don't really question anything and
that's not the that's not what we that's
not what we swore on oath to do
um and so you know this passion that I
developed for my country and my
Constitution uh in my career as an
officer I feel almost a little bit
betrayed because
um there seems to be the sentiment well
well the military owned you well you
need to get the vaccine because that's
what you signed up for
um I didn't sign up to take anything
with mRNA in it when I entered the
military in 2015 as an Academy Cadet and
nor when I commissioned in 2019 and so
you know there's so many arguments to be
made for that but the bottom line is
that when I stood up and said well this
is a violation of my constitutional
religious beliefs or consciously
basically excuse me religious beliefs
that are founded in the constitution in
the First Amendment but also
as an officer I think this this order is
lawful unlawful and immoral people
scoffed that and they said well you know
like it I agree with you but there's
nothing I can do about it and I hear
that a lot from Military Officers is I
agree with you but I can't do anything
because that's just what the order came
down to and I think that's pretty
contrary to our foundational beliefs as
a military and as a country
I wholeheartedly agree with you and I
would say
um what you're reflecting is something
that I think is part of a bigger pattern
um I know that as a scientist I have
been under tremendous pressure to
acknowledge the truth of things that I
can tell you are not true now I don't
know why I'm being told not to do the
job I trained for but that message has
come through loud and clear on every
channel do not behave as a scientist
behave as an advocate for a policy that
I frankly believe to be uh
radically Reckless
and I think we can say the same thing
about journalists for example right
they're being told not to report certain
stories only to say things that adhere
to a particular perspective
we could say the same thing about social
media platforms which apparently the
executive branch is telling should have
a slant in what sorts of discussions
they allow and what sorts of posts are
tolerated
so I guess the question is how many
different oh and maybe the worst of
these
is doctors
doctors are being yes
coerced into violating the Hippocratic
Oath right as if they have a higher
obligation to this policy of mass
vaccination than they do to do no harm
to their patients so at every realm
where I see
um this policy being
discussed or debated everybody is being
told don't do the job you train for
right don't be a doctor don't be a
scientist don't be a journalist don't
defend your Constitution and how many of
those Realms would you have to see
before you said you know what that isn't
incompetence that's a pattern everybody
is being told not to do their job why
would that happen what are the what are
the least
frightening explanations for everybody
in Civilization being told don't do your
job right and you know the problem is we
can come up with the least bad
explanation but they're still pretty bad
yeah well I tell you this Brett there's
an old joke and Olivia will appreciate I
know she knows this one but it's uh once
is once is random twice as a coincidence
but three times his enemy action
yeah I was uh hesitating to be the one
to introduce that because I am obviously
in the worst position to to say it but I
you know I do think there's some wisdom
there right we're looking at something
that behaves like enemy action and you
know my feeling you know as somebody who
tries to be very careful about I don't
even think in terms of conspiracy
theories you have hypotheses they
function just as a scientific hypothesis
does they make predictions you try to
figure out whether you try to prove them
false and in this case the
um
least terrifying explanation for the
pattern of behavior that we see is that
um
our system has been captured by
something and this has become uh purely
about money and it has
um absolute indifference to human
suffering and death right for sure and
you and indifference to the well-being
of the nation in the long term
and this wasn't you know um I don't know
if you know
um Marcia angle she was the director of
the doctor medical doctor first female
editor of the New England Journal of
Medicine
long time barely yeah she wrote a book
that came out I think in 2000 I don't
know six eight it was the darling of and
you'll appreciate this the political
left at the time because she was telling
truth to power and she was she detailed
in that book I think it's called how
Farmall deceives us or I forget what the
title is the full title but essentially
the book details in her role as
um head of the New England Journal of
Medicine she just lays out that in in
her view and experience the
pharmaceutical industry had the
regulatory capture of the Food and Drug
Administration by Pharma was was
complete during her watch and the book
was hailed as a as a Triumph in how
wonderful and truthy you know and how it
told the real truth and then now if you
go look at you can find articles that
are sort of why Marsha angle wasn't
really correct about Pharma and you know
suddenly Pfizer has gone from being you
know the largest criminal fine in
history to being the savior of of
mankind mind you know it's uh we live in
we live in an amazing time I I wanted to
at least throw out you know when you
talk about this idea of the worst the
least the least worst uh possible
um thing is I would just say that you
know
while this has been going down you've
got uh I think it's something like 10 of
the last 14 FDA directors
now sit on boards for pharmaceutical
companies my favorite is Scott Gottlieb
was uh 2017-19 director of the FDA he of
course winds up at Pfizer and then the
Trump guy Steve Hahn comes in from 2019
to 21 uh in January of
2022
or 2021 he approves Spike vax less than
six months later in June he's sitting on
the board of directors for the company
that owns
moderna
which itself took DARPA money
um I mean at some at some point you know
the FDA owns uh Robert Kennedy at
Children's Health defense made that made
the claim that uh
that the FDA is fundamentally a
pharmaceutical company with regulatory
power and he said oh they've got 31
patents and and somebody decided to do a
funny fact check on Robert Kennedy and
and they said fact check it's not 31
patents it's 57 and they own you know
it's I mean they own something like um
they've got a four billion dollar IP
portfolio
you know so I mean 42 of the the vaccine
regulatory budget for enforcement 42 of
it is uh paid for by user fees from the
pharmaceutical industry so if I paid 42
of your salary you were a regulator I
mean how could you Poss how do we
pretend that this is all that this is
all okay I mean it's
it's just it's as bad as you could
possibly imagine you know it'd be like
the SEC having a stock portfolio
you know you you wouldn't think that
that was a you know what could go wrong
you know I mean and yet here we are
that's this is all those are all matters
of public record you know yeah I must
say this is the part of it that is
hardest for me to understand is that I
don't think there's anything especially
new about the idea of regulatory capture
right that's a phrase I've I've known
for you know a decade and a half right
it's a well-known phenomenon Pharma is
known to be among the um the worst cases
of this phenomenon it's been thoroughly
academically documented and suddenly in
this case we have people marching in
lockstep as you know I mean I in fact
have been trying to pose the question to
people to wake them up what fraction of
the policy that we see surrounding these
so-called vaccines do you think is the
result of uh undue influence by Pharma
right and my feeling is if you say zero
I know you're either lying or a fool
right so if it's not zero then really
the question we ought to be discussing
is okay it's somewhere you know between
zero and a hundred
this is looking a lot closer to a
hundred to me and it behaves like a
hundred now
that's what I want to hear it sure looks
like a hundred but you know let let's
get back to the central matter here this
is one thing when we're dealing with the
civilian population I mean it's
jaw dropping and I struggle to find
words to uh
to even encapsulate how terrifying it is
to watch this thing not even interested
in vaccinating as many people who as
will accept it but strong arming people
into it but this becomes so much more
dangerous when it's the military to whom
we are doing this because the role the
military plays in preserving this system
is obviously you know literally at the
front line so
um and the fact that the mandates have
held on more tenaciously in that context
presumably that's because
the chain of command already has a leg
up on telling members of the military
what to do right and the circumstances
in which a member of the military is
Justified in refusing uh an order are
you know those are extreme circumstances
and so I mean a
I do see a kind of turning of the tables
here right we in the civilian population
cannot leave our military behind if we
have successfully fended off these
mandates because they were medically
absurd to begin with
um and extremely dangerous the younger
you were the more dangerous they were
this is about the future of that
civilian population for us now to walk
away from that issue while the military
is still exposed to this danger is not
only foolish from the point of view of
our long-term well-being in the civilian
population but it's it's
um uh it's it's a betrayal of the
service that the military provides for
the nation so
can we talk about what that's like to be
um
forgotten to have your mandates persist
after the civilian population has more
or less escaped its
yeah Brett this has been incredibly
troubling I think one of the challenges
that I saw was the Secretary of Defense
mandated the covid-19 vaccine in August
of 2021 at that point after over a year
and a half of living with covid we'd
lost 28 military service members
now obviously any loss of life is you
know terrible thing but that number is
far eclipsed by suicides motorcycle
accidents you know alcohol-related
incidents
after implementing the Mandate by
October late October that number had
more than doubled and we'd gone to 70
military deaths that were you know
labeled due to covid and those are the
dod Zone the department of defense's own
numbers
at that point it shocked me that
um considering there was no parallel in
the civilian population the Department
of Defense didn't feel a need to stop
and reassess the order that they had put
out
having witnessed such an incredible loss
of life
um
I don't understand what's going on and
to your point with you know capture or
whatever is happening clearly clearly
things are not where they need to be one
of the things that the military is known
for and as a prior Aviator one of the
things we always do after every mission
is to debrief and so you know you go you
prep for a mission you fly your mission
hopefully you get the bad guys and then
you come back and you talk about it and
you say hey guys how can we do this
better in the future and we haven't
seemed to do that at all with any of
these policies which is just not aligned
with military culture and has been
really disturbing you know it's shocking
frankly
yeah and look I I again I know that we
have to be very careful about
what hypotheses we entertain here but
this is another data point
the idea that you would not reflect on
the policy and figure out what worked
and what didn't and what was its effect
on our Readiness and how can we fix it
exactly that is also consistent with you
know I will try to find some alternative
to enemy action but it is beyond
incompetent right an incompetent entity
might review what happened incompetently
but the desire to ignore what happened
and not improve the policy is is um
it is only consistent at the the
absolute least pernicious explanation is
total indifference to the well-being of
service members and the Readiness of our
military force well to your point about
absolutely that's the least bad it could
be to your point about the military
getting left behind I think you can
maybe stir up a little bit of passion
for those that are listening to this and
I thank you for taking the time to
listen is that
um you know
it's not just the simple fact that that
service members are being coerced into
taking this vaccine it's it's what's
happening with the coercion you know
from my personal experience I you know I
I literally spent my entire life trying
to be a fighter pilot I remember
distinctly thinking that my eighth grade
science fair project somehow mattered
for me getting into the Air Force
Academy
um and it's been my passion and so I
love flying I absolutely adore flying I
think it's the most fun job in the world
it's an absolute blast and so you know
to be grounded now for over a year and
watch my peers and my friends you know
put on put on the G suit in the flight
suit and go fly and rage around and hear
their stories and uh it's it's it makes
it makes me a little bummed out I mean
it's it's frustrating and it's saddening
and my story isn't even close to the
worst of it I recently spoke to a
service member uh who was told
after he got a federal injunction
protecting him from discharge that he
had two options he could either get the
vaccine or the military would move him
to the middle of nowhere Alaska with his
wife and kids because he wasn't
considered Deployable and they thought
that maybe moving him to Alaska might
convince him he ended up getting the
vaccine over that uh just because he
knew that moving his family to the
center of Alaska it was just not
something that was even remotely
sustainable and keep in mind again that
this is after he had a federal
injunction protecting him from discharge
so the coercion's not over and and this
kind of sentiment that's directed
towards these service members who are
vaccinated is exactly what's forcing
people out I mean even our own fighter
pilot Community is is
leaving because of of things like this
our fighter pilot retention in 2021 was
below 30 that means less than 30 percent
of people who finish their 10-year
contract as an aviator are staying in
the military uh we are hemorrhaging
people at a time when we are already
1650 Pilots short in the Air Force alone
and in 2017 the chief of staff of the
Air Force called a 1500 pilot shortage a
crisis so we are in a pilot crisis and
like damage and the pilot seem to be
specifically targeted in these mandates
we are in a crisis of pilots in the
military and that's a humongous
Readiness issue and it's policies like
this vaccine program where people feel
like they're alone and left behind and
isolated and attacked that's that's
making people that are even vaccinated
to go you know what I think I'm going to
leave this organization because it
doesn't seem to represent my values or
it doesn't seem to care about me
um and I would encourage the civilian
population and all the viewers to start
speaking up about that because that kind
of sentiment is exactly how our military
crumbles and in a time like today with
China and Ukraine in Russia that's
that's a dangerous precedent to set for
our military when we need every single
service member possible
yeah I mean it's it's particularly acute
with respect to Pilots for a number of
reasons I mean you know this is not my
area of expertise but I can see first of
all that the amount we invest in the
training of Pilots is disproportionate
because the job is so Technical and so
difficult the equipment we entrust to
Pilots is extremely expensive and so and
you know here's where I'm really
speculating but I would imagine that
um as difficult a job as it is to become
a fighter pilot
uh under
simulated conditions that In the Heat of
battle the quality of Pilots is certain
to be a a central question that is to
say who can keep their their cool enough
to not only fly the plane but operate
the weapons and you know put themselves
in the right spot
so
there's something shocking about
you know of you know we're not this is
not the indifference of the command to
the Infantry which would be bad enough
right these are highly trained
professionals who are being strong-armed
into taking a vaccine that frankly is
maximally dangerous in uh in a pilot who
uh can't afford to have a sudden heart
attack in the air and you know that that
data is slow to emerge but
um the let's put it this way if you pay
attention to Medical circles in which
people are seeing Adverse Events
they are not only seeing
um anomalous heart attacks in young
healthy people they are also seeing
things like
automobile accidents uh on the rise in a
spectacular way that is consistent with
the idea that people who would
ordinarily have gotten from A to B
without a problem suddenly have a severe
medical incident behind the wheel and
the car careen's off the road that's all
the worse if you know your fifteen
thousand feet in the air
um
so you know
to the extent that there is no medical
argument for vaccinating a young healthy
person with these mRNA vaccines in the
worst case
um it's even worse when that person's
job involves extreme uh pressures on
their physiology and the necessity that
they stay absolutely competent until the
plane is back on the ground am I wrong
about that to your to your body you've
got it and I'll just add to it Brett go
ahead to your point on on the data that
you mentioned and how it's there's not a
lot of data
um I independently Quantified exactly
what you're talking about in terms of of
the pilots that could we could stand to
lose from these vaccine mandates uh I
worked with 350 unvaccinated Pilots to
generate a
Grassroots if you will study on exactly
what those Pilots mean to our national
security and and in that study of 352
Pilots which is only about half of the
unvaccinated pilots that I'm aware of in
the Department of Defense they are worth
7.8 billion dollars in tax money and
that's including salary and training
costs and everything else that's only
350 and that's 7.8 billion dollars
that's a big number and the average
years of service of those Pilots is 14
years so we're not standing to lose uh
younger inexperienced Pilots like myself
we're sending to lose extremely
experienced aviators with deployments in
actual combat experience overseas and
that's not something that you can just
recruit in uh and fix the problem
immediately as a military so these are
extremely valuable people and also their
families you know there's 800 dependents
in in that in that study as well and so
you know this has largely gone ignored
by Congress which I think is unfortunate
and I hope that many members of Congress
start to see the study that we release
because although it's not an official
will study and to some degree some of
those numbers are our estimates they're
conservative estimates at the very least
and you know 14 years of service is
certainly something that's not an
estimate that's real hard data and so
with that on top of the injuries I also
helped to generate a congressional
injury report that that talks about and
has Medical Data from service members
who have been injured by the vaccine and
some of those injuries include a fighter
pilot who got pericarditis has been
grounded for seven months there was one
enlisted service member that had four
strokes after getting the vaccine uh and
so these are these are serious injuries
and Florida just recently a few days ago
released a study where they said that
they're no longer recommending the covid
vaccine any version of the coveted
vaccine for your mRNA vaccines at the
very least for people in the 18 to 39
male age group and that's based off of a
self-controlled case study that they did
on their own data and so uh you know
it's starting to come out at least in
Florida and other locations across the
world that they're not recommending this
vaccine to people so I I can't see how
in light of that information that we
could be recommending that when we know
for a fact that this vaccine is maiming
and injuring our most competent and
qualified military members
maiming and injuring people who are
perfectly capable of fending on I mean I
believe covet is a serious disease let's
be clear about that but young people who
are healthy and the military is
disproportionately composed of such
people are perfectly capable of fending
off covid naturally it is their best
option and these so-called vaccines have
such a powerful risk profile that it
just there is no medical argument for
this right
um and you know I think you've done a
good job of exploring all of the various
ways that this
impinges on our our Readiness you know
there's the financial investment there's
the the risk to Pilots you point out uh
something I had missed which is that
you're losing the experienced pilots who
are obviously uh essential to are being
able to to fight in the air right this
really it couldn't be more foolish
English you also point to another group
of people who is effectively being
expected not to do their job here which
is members of Congress right the members
of Congress have a patriotic duty to
protect our military not just for the
military's sake which would be
sufficient on its own but because of the
role the military plays in protecting
the nation the fact is
I don't care if you're going to lose an
election for doing the right thing you
got yourself elected to congress
presumably because you wanted to make
better law well here's your opportunity
right we have an obvious travesty of
justice and a hazard to the nation's
military Readiness
where is the the uprising in Congress
that forces the federal government to
relent
and my understanding is
they also take an oath to support and
defend the Constitution so you know I'll
turn over go ahead Dale but they also
they have the same oath as we do this is
yep same oath uh and of course we know
the if we're being really honest about
political issues here you know there's
no bill that uh Republicans could could
get passed right now to do anything in
the house there's discussion and
certainly as as a lawyer working on a
lot of these cases we've had some
discussions with Senator Johnson's
office and a lot of these folks but
um I don't I don't put any hope that
that that's going to Magic itself
because president you know Biden is is
he'll veto anything so I presumably he's
not going to sign a bill that says
whoops I was wrong since he's the one
who man you know uh ensured that this
mandate is happening and so the you know
we're gonna have to find a way out of
this uh in the courts I think or you
know because I don't see how that's
gonna come through a house or a senate
that's divided and you know you're being
you're being too easy on them
I don't expect
it either but that is people falling
down on their obligation to their Nation
to the oath that they took to their
fellow man to their fellow citizen the
fact is many of us and I include myself
here have taken very substantial risks
to say the right things that is to say
to explore this issue honestly and
expose what is taking place and the
costs have been high for many of us I
mean as this group of people can
illustrate and you know as you all know
for each one of you sitting here there
are dozens of others with stories of
what they've faced so
the the fact that people will not you
know look the military is composed of
people who believe that there are Hills
on which one must be willing to die
right that there there are things worth
fighting for that's the nature of the
military and the fact that on the
civilian side
not only are people not willing to die
for anything they're not willing to risk
their reputation or their job over
anything is a sad commentary on
um on what we have become so I I expect
more of these people to the extent that
President Biden has overseen a mandate
that has been a disaster of course the
right thing for him to do is to give a
hell of a speech to that effect right of
course that's the right thing to do and
I would respect him a great deal more if
he did that rather than keep doubling
down on a bad policy that's killing
people well Congress certainly this this
group is uh is uh for some perspective
Brett but the clients of which John and
Olivia I've got three different cases
and a total of about 900 maybe a
thousand clients right now military
clients and I took on so many for a lot
of reasons but one of them was that I
thought there was something to be I knew
there were so many people knocking on my
door as Olivia said largely out of this
book that I had written about the pride
higher iteration of this in fact Olivia
would be would be arguably Justified and
claim you know this is her second time
in her career within a 20-year career
that she's facing is facing an illegal
Department of Defense vaccine mandate I
mean they they got shut down the first
time for the anthrax one we gotta we got
a court order shutting that down but you
know if the group that I represent I
thought it would it would be helpful in
Mass but there are I think if we were
our own Air Force
we would be the 16th largest Air Force
in the world like just my clients would
be the sixth the world's 16th largest
Air Force we have between pilots crew
we've got heavy lift you know C5 Pilots
uh c-141 pilot C-130 Pilots the entire
aircraft range we've got
um v22 Osprey pilots in the Marine Corps
we've got F-35 Pilots we've got crew
chiefs load Masters I mean I I represent
qualitatively almost the Battalion level
you know of officers and enlisted who
all know this is this is wrong and and
they're all getting the boot you know
it's it's unfortunate yeah
um all right I I want to make sure that
we
um cover certain things in the time that
we have left and I know that there's
more for both Olivia and John that
should be explored in terms of what you
experienced uh in the military prior to
these mandates what you have experienced
in terms of uh
consequences from standing up against
the mandates I want to talk about uh the
question of the religious
um exemption how it's functioning what
it might be based on so let's make sure
we don't miss any of those topics
um either one of you feel sorry I should
be I should be directing better than I
am but does either one of you feel like
this is a moment to jump in and fill in
part of that story
sure John kind of spoke to some of the
challenges he's faced for me
um
you know 20 years you're going to see
some crazy stuff and in the past I've
actually witnessed other violations of
law what I found striking is in the past
when when we would uncover some sort of
um some action that was either illegal
or you know discriminatory or there was
something wrong that was going on
leadership had a genuine interest in
what was occurring and they sought to
resolve that issue as quickly as
possible you know it was an all hands on
deck effort there was absolute
transparency we brought in lawyers or
whoever we needed to bring in to ensure
that the wrongs that were occurring were
remedied immediately that hasn't been
the case for you know anything related
to covet 19. so
as I said earlier you know my family and
I we were headed out to China to go be
diplomats and
um when we were grounded our stuff our
household goods had already been packed
out so everything we owned all of our
worldly possessions had been put into
boxes and were put um in a warehouse
here in DC and we're just waiting for
you know us to arrive in China so that
they could send our stuff overseas
our household goods were held for an
entire year before the military agreed
to release them and anytime I would ask
about it you know I was kind of told
well you know how to get your stuff
Medical's right down the road and that
was with a religious accommodation
pending uh absolutely illegal not
something that you can do that was just
one example of this sort of you know
challenges that I've personally faced
I've had training canceled or denied
I've had Leaf chips requests for
vacation denied I didn't get to go to
one of my daughter's medical
appointments to my sister's baby shower
when things were really stressful I I'd
been told I've been told that I was
going to get kicked out of the military
two weeks prior to my 20 years and I had
several people that I know kind of pull
me to the side and say are you really
really willing to risk your retirement
over this
um and for me the Constitution is worth
it you know absolutely I'm willing to
risk my retirement and fortunately at
this point it won't come that I guess
we'll see but uh most recently I've
received an adverse Fitness report
that's like a performance evaluation in
the civilian world I am being
recommended for a board of inquiry based
on not taking two emergency use
authorized covid-19 tests so you know
the vaccines aren't the only emergency
use authorized products out there covet
tests and face masks are also emergency
use authorized products and they have
the same legal protections that we
discussed earlier Americans to include
service members have the right to accept
or refuse these products at any time
um and I was also kicked out of my
command and I'm actually you know in the
middle of going to a new Command right
now and all of that was for speaking up
at a town hall at the agency I worked
for and questioning the legality of it
you know one of the points I made I just
I keep hearing from DOD Department of
Defense leadership I apologize I'll try
not to use acronyms it's a language in
and of itself in the military
um one of the things DOD we've got I
agree you can uh you can leave us in the
dust pretty easily
so you know I questioned the dod
mandates and and one of the things that
I keep hearing from senior military
leaders
is that they're just following policy
and uh one of one of the things that I
like to point out is that a
policy never trumps law
certainly not the Constitution
and then B do you need policy has been
wrong in the past you know and I like to
remind people we used to have don't ask
don't tell we didn't allow African
Americans in the service we didn't allow
women in the service and now in
hindsight we look back and we realize
that those policies were misplaced and I
just asked people you know at the point
now where the president of the United
States has stated that we no longer are
in a crisis you know covert is not an
emergency anymore
I think he said the pandemic was over
specifically
um why is it that we continue to drive
out all of these service members coerce
people take these negative actions
against each of our service members and
again we're talking about over 80 000
people here people who want to serve
their country people who are actively
trying to support and defend the
constitution in taking the actions that
we're taking right now uh the punishment
that's being inflicted on our service
members is unacceptable and and really
disturbing
well again uh I I wish it didn't I wish
I could be on the other side of this
argument but
um this again matches exactly what you
would predict if somebody was not
interested in our long-term well-being
as a nation because
uh for whatever reason the policies that
are so devastating here are
um being Advanced most aggressively by
what I call the Blue Team uh the
Democratic party of which I've been a
lifelong member but uh I I can't even
recognize that party now and so if you
were interested in keeping that party in
power so that it could continue to
advance bad policy
but you also uh were interested in
degrading military Readiness then the
mandates might persist in the military
while they are withdrawn in advance of
midterm elections or something like that
uh in the civilian population I mean I I
hear myself saying that and I I know how
it sounds on the other hand I'm a
scientist and what I do is I look at
patterns and I eliminate uh potential
explanations based on the fact that they
don't fit until we're down to a small
number of explanations that might might
underlie the pattern and in this case
that is a very unfortunate process that
points in a direction that I think ought
to alarm every American
um John do you want to speak to uh
what's happened to you as a result of
your stance uh on the on the so-called
vaccines certainly so
uh really this all began for me in
September of 2021 if I remember
correctly September 21st 2021 I was
called into my Commander's office and I
was told
the mandates here I know you don't want
to get the vaccine you've expressed that
to me
um and you said you're going to apply
for religious accommodation so here's
your option you either apply for a
religious accommodation
or a medical exemption
or you get the vaccine and that and of
itself is fine that's that's within the
realm of the legal structure and in the
regulatory structure of the military is
affording the option to get an exemption
for the vaccine if there's a mandate
and so I applied for a religious
accommodation but there was a catch and
that catch was well if you apply for
religious accommodation you're going to
be grounded and you're no longer going
to be able to train in the F-16
and uh that that is where the issue kind
of begins because the Air Force's own
policies on religious accommodation say
that no adverse training decisions can
be made based off of the application of
a religious accommodation so it was
immediately contrary to the Air Force's
own policies in this but nonetheless I
pushed through because you know I have a
firm religious belief and it's rooted in
the use of fetal cells for testing in in
the coveted vaccines
um and I'm a devout Catholic and I'm
pro-life so I I decided to press forward
with that and that was been my concern
since the beginning of these vaccines
and so I requested that religious
accommodation I was grounded and then I
immediately filed an equal opportunity
complaint uh against my command for
grounding me uh over that and to this
day to this day a year later now I have
still not heard anything about that
equal opportunity complaint even though
I cited all the policy I I've had no
communication no education of that of
that complaint which is which is
concerning of itself that the Equal
Opportunity program is either that
backed up or is is somehow you know
Burying my paperwork I'm not going to
make any accusations but I I was
ultimately denied that religious
accommodation and I appealed it
but what's interesting is in my denial
there were some interesting interesting
arguments made about about why I had to
get the vaccine and some of those
arguments included well you would have
to wear a mask if you were flying and uh
you can't wear a mask when you're flying
an F-16 and that's strange because masks
have never been required for air crew in
any capacity whatsoever and I assume
they mean like an n95 mask or something
but I I mean I wear a mask when I fly
and I'm in a jet by myself so it's I
mean like you know the closest we'll get
is like 20 feet away from each other and
that's that's so that's social
distancing
um and I'm literally in like a bubble
it's like a coveted bubble right yeah I
mean there's canopy I
the absurdity of this is almost
incalculable I mean this is a virus that
so far does not appear to transmit
Outdoors you're in a plane
alone
and
there is no conceivable way that you
could transmit this virus to anyone or
catch it from anyone
in this context right what's more I mean
as if that weren't in and of itself
Catch 22 level absurdity yeah right the
vaccines don't prevent you from Catching
or transmitting this virus and therefore
the whole basis for this is about
protecting at best and the argument is
thin as can be but at best these
vaccines can be argued to protect
vulnerable people
from severe consequences after they have
caught the thing right that argument
can't be made for somebody young and
healthy like yourself and so
the only thing that protects this policy
is that the people advancing it don't
have to explain why right it can't be
explained there is no logic here that
could explain why the military
wants you to get this to protect you in
your plane it makes no sense no sense
exactly right if the military was
interested in you being protected they
would want you not to get the vaccine
because it carries risks and you're
better off fending off the disease uh
with uh your own natural immunity and
and speaking of which Brett you know the
other part of this is that what's been
going on that's lost and it's a part of
the lawsuit is what you just said is
natural immunity you know I grew up I
grew up when you know it's pretty well
established that for example I had
chickenpox I don't you know if you did
when you were growing up as kid that
that meant that I was never going to get
a Chickenpox vaccine yeah because it had
been well established you know as old as
I am and I think we're probably about
the same age we're probably pretty close
in age but you know it was pretty well
established that it's contraindicated
for you to get a vaccine or a shot you
know a prophylactic shot for a disease
you've already had and so if you had
chickenpox you weren't going to get the
chickenpox vaccine so we've got a huge
swath of the military you know given
where we are now two and a half years in
on a respiratory virus most people have
had it and and would you know have some
form of immunity to it and and the
interesting thing is the dod in 2013
acknowledge natural immunity it's right
in the dod regulation on chemopropylaxis
AR 40-562 right in there says you should
be exempt it's a preferential that you
should be exempt if you've already had
this and it is amazing how quickly when
this came out I mean I went right to
that because I had experienced this I
was telling people hey put this in your
request that you've got natural immunity
go get tested if you're positive you
should be exempt we should in all these
medical exemptions the natural immunity
the entire that regulatory framework the
biology that underlies the entire basis
for these things just went I mean out
the window and people who had prior
anaphylaxis I had clients who couldn't
get couldn't get their commands to
acknowledge they're like well you have
to prove now that you'll have
anaphylaxis to this vaccine I'm like
that's that's an insane I mean this is
just I can't believe anybody says that
and so you know to your to your point I
know you think I've maybe been a little
light on them Brett but I mean I I feel
pretty strongly like the religious
accommodation process isn't when it's
supposed to be you file the religious
combination nothing happens to you as
John pointed out I tell people that when
you take action to harm someone's career
after they've filed for a religious
accommodation that's not a religious
accommodation policy that's a religious
targeting policy yes yeah right it's
religious persecution right and and what
you're doing the other thing is we don't
know how many people who saw this and I
can tell you I mean I I'm aware and I've
done a little work on there's 42 Navy or
42 chaplains who are suing military
chaplains who are suing over this
vaccine in the eastern district of
Virginia
um that case is Alvarado and they'll
they've been clear in their affidavits
that from the beginning they were told
um
that it was going to be DOD policy they
weren't going to Grant any so this has
been I mean from the get-go they you
know there were policies that were in
effect where the the dod had made the
decision
that even all of its own regulations
were going to be violated in order to to
let people know that we're going to
hammer you regardless you know they're
not so we're not going to follow the
policies and we don't even know how many
people didn't bother filing for
religious accommodation or whatever
because they were told there's no point
you're going to get kicked out you're
gonna you know I mean I know John and
Olivia know that that for every one of
them who's had the courage to stand up
there's probably another 10 who who just
work out we're broken because of what
the dod has done yeah this is uh this is
the tragedy of it is how many people you
know had the objection and the concern
and uh knuckled under because
fighting you know the dod is is too
frightening a prospect
um I I will say that again
the
the pattern is unmistakable yeah
whatever this policy is it is not
medically based exactly right and again
I don't know I can't imagine if you
talked to me 10 years ago and told me
this sentence is going to come out of
your mouth I would have said huh what
would have to have happened in order for
me to say that but we have a policy in
which we are mandating something that we
are calling a vaccine that is really far
more radical than a vaccine that is not
apparently based on medical well-being
it's not that it misunderstands medical
well-being it's indifferent to Medical
well-being and the idea that that policy
whatever it is whatever its purpose is
so important
that we are going to violate
constitutional principles like your
right to religious belief
um is absolutely shocking
and we should get into what you know you
mentioned John the issue of fetal cells
which although you and I might see that
issue differently in the particulars I
see it as a perfectly valid reason to
object in the strongest terms if you
hold certain religious beliefs that are
commonly held by many Americans then
that is an offense it is an offense and
I could come up with analogies from
other contexts I think I will hold back
from doing so but nonetheless the idea
that if you believe that
um
those fetal cells are effectively uh
human beings deceased human beings that
were utilized in the production of these
of these vaccines then it seems to me
that your right to object to them is is
absolute and yet
it falls on deaf ears I mean it what is
it like when somebody tells you that
that belief isn't sufficient to justify
your uh refusing a vaccine that actually
has no medical benefit to offer you
anyway you know it's um
yeah I'm a Catholic and I'm sure as you
know and everyone knows Catholics are
criticized quite often and that's fine
so honestly being told that my beliefs
are are uh invalid or whatever is is not
anything new
um and it's not really anything that
totally fazes me because I'm totally set
and rooted in my beliefs and they give
me a good life and I'm blessed so that
that is unfortunate it's frustrating at
the very least to say that that these
accommodations are being denied because
you're not valid where where it's really
truly frustrating for me is the fact
that
um it's it's contrary to the
Constitution and my oath to the
Constitution and it's contrary to the
policies and and more importantly
um I think that it's the perfect
compromise and that's really what what
confuses me the most is the fact that if
you were just simply to Grant these
religious accommodations which are
essentially lawfully required to be
granted all things considered
um you can still have your vaccine
mandate you can still have your vaccine
mandated people are allergic to some of
the ingredients in the vaccine you give
them an exam an exemption you can still
have your vaccine mandated if you grant
religious accommodations you don't even
have to overturn it you can just grant
these exemptions uh and everyone's happy
and although there are deeper rooted
issues with the legality of the Mandate
and everything else at the very least I
think this would be a lot less of a
problem if those were just granted
certainly from the perspective of
National Security but nonetheless yeah I
would say that
um it does feel like religious
persecution
to be ignored and to scream out into the
void if you will about this and what's
more is is
that people just don't simply understand
they think I'm a crazy person or they
tell people that well there's no
organized religion really that's popular
and common in America that says that you
can't take the vaccine when that's
actually really not that true the
Archbishop of the military diocese
himself said that to deny a religious
accommodation for those with sincerely
held beliefs would be contrary to
federal law and morally abhorrent and
that that's the Archbishop of the
military diocese who is quite literally
a Catholic figurehead in the military uh
and so we're to some degree I wouldn't
say being lied to but but being told
things that aren't necessarily true when
they say that well like your faith can't
even you you don't want to Faith for
that and I know military members
especially the enlisted Corps and the
younger guys who have been told by even
chaplains that well your religious
belief isn't valid um that that that's
not part of Christianity uh and that's
just that that's not how Christianity
works for one and and also not how it
works within the realm of the law and to
tell people that they can't have a
religious accommodation
um when they request it is is concerning
and a little bit scary if if you I can
be totally honest
well I I think it's actually terrifying
and uh cards on the table I'm not a
religious person I don't consider myself
an atheist but I'm very close to it I
don't believe in an interventionist God
but I have to say there's something
about
this disease the apparent origin of it
which is unnatural the result of at best
um scientific hubris
and the fact of this
incredibly radical medical Intervention
which is bound
Heather and I spotted at the beginning
that this was such an unusual way to
intervene in bodily physiology that the
risks were just almost uncountable the
number of ways this could go wrong was
very large from the beginning even
before we knew that it did go wrong
but the whole thing to me like I
struggle for a term that isn't there is
something Unholy about this right again
I'm not a religious person but the idea
that someone thinks that I might be or
you might be required to accept this
intervention despite the fact that it
doesn't actually work epidemiologically
to prevent the spread of the thing right
if it did the question might be somewhat
different but it doesn't and yet
somebody would tell us that we are
required to accept this and that are
sincerely held belief that it is the
wrong thing to do is immaterial is
shocking it's shocking and in this case
you have an objection you know I I I
will um
I will say that the belief that
Catholics hold about fetuses is a it
doesn't have to be perfectly
philosophically consistent but it is
right if you believe in a God who
intervenes in the Affairs of humans that
decides that a child will come into the
world right then everything about your
objection here flows very naturally from
that belief which frankly although I
don't believe it
nobody on Earth can say it isn't true
right it is a simple matter of this is
where my understanding of the universe
leads me nobody can tell you it isn't
right and if it is right then of course
it makes the subjection very obvious and
robust and to be stared down by a
military that can't explain in rational
terms why it should want you to take
this thing in the first place is
it's just it's jaw-dropping
but
um so I want to get a little bit we
talked in a prior conversation
about
the nature of the Constitutional
protection for religious beliefs and
I've alluded to it a little bit here but
I think it's likely that virtually
everybody in my audience has only a
passing familiarity at best with these
protections so do one or all of you want
to speak to what the Constitution
actually says how do we know if your
religious uh belief is a is a valid uh
reason to be exempt
well I'll I'll take uh I'll do a little
of the heavy lifting as a lawyer just
because I'm fairly familiar with it but
um one of the interesting aspects to the
the government looking into the courts
have said essentially look it's not for
us to pass judgment on whether our
religious belief is valid or not and so
it's largely can you articulate uh uh
you know something that's
coherent it doesn't even have to be
really I don't want to say logical it
it's really do you have a religious
belief and in that sense they're really
just trying to say it's a belief
about which
um you know how you believe the universe
is organized and matters outside of sort
of it's not a political assertion but I
will say that there are you know the
line gets pretty close there are people
who feel for example I represented a
airline pilot who put in for a religious
accommodation and part of his his belief
was it was scriptural based and there
was certainly the fetal cell thing but
one of the things he said was that I
thought was interesting was that the
government actions in this case
started to look more and more
remnant of
scripture and that the government's
desire to force this no matter what
started to make it look like its own
religion like this is a you know you
must get the jab and that the the
secular humanism that underlies this now
has become its own religious kind of
dogma and and his stake was hey I'm you
know I only have one God and so I I
can't serve and there's a lot of other
scriptural things about whether putting
a I mean I have a devout Orthodox Jewish
client as well and there's a lot of
Torah passages that certainly suggests
that it would be
that it would not be proper for an
observant uh observant person to do this
particularly given the technology you
know you've alluded to this breath that
they're not vaccines
their treatments fundamentally since
they don't prevent transmission they
fall right into therapies and they were
you know the uh
the folks who made them in SEC filings
referred them as Gene therapies they did
it before other regulatory bodies and
then the the FDA realized they went
right after they announced this program
they switched the definition on the
website of vaccine
and so
um all of that made you know one one
client say yeah this this is looking
like I'm being asked to it's a loyalty
test you know it's a and it's it's
forcing people into the idea of choosing
the this over their God or their beliefs
and so I don't even think you really
need to get too deep into whether agk
cell line 293 was used there's there's a
lot of other reasons why people of
conscience should and could be outside
of it and the Supreme Court would say at
least the case law says that's good
enough you know there is no it's not not
like you need to have the pope back you
up in order to be entitled to some
really you know protection of conscience
am I right my understanding is that the
test is effectively is your belief
earnestly held right faking in order to
get out of something or do you actually
believe that and if you actually believe
it then it isn't a question of whether
it makes sense or others believe it
right am I right about that yeah yeah
you've got it pretty much sincerely held
belief sincerely hell belief so I would
also say you know I mean I think this is
very interesting territory because again
uh
I'm pretty close to what would have been
called a secular humanist or is called a
secular humanist I'm certainly a
science first
maybe I don't want to say that but from
the point of view of what I believe to
be true I'm definitely science first
right I believe that values have a
different status but but science is my
Guiding Light from the point of view of
what is and is not true and even from
that perspective
am I allowed you know if I was working
in a university still would I be allowed
to opt out of
these so-called vaccines on the basis
that I understand how immunity works
that I believe more strongly in my
body's ability
to fight this virus based on Ancient
capacities that I have on board rather
than a radical new technology in which a
corporation decides that it wants to
conscript my cells into becoming
factories for a protein that is known to
be physiologically dangerous it seems to
me that I am well within my rights to
say actually I believe that my immunity
is better than that plan I actually yeah
I know that go ahead I actually have a
story for you on exactly that so uh when
I first requested a religious
accommodation another individual that
was requesting one as well another
fighter pilot actually processed a
religious accommodation for ethical
veganism
um and that was her her reasoning for
why she requested a religious
accommodation was that she was a vegan
and that she couldn't take this vaccine
because of it and that but essentially
it was her de facto religion because it
was essentially her world view on life
and It ultimately got processed she
ended up getting the vaccine under the
pressure of being grounded which is very
unfortunate but
um there was no they didn't really know
what to do with it but they're like okay
I guess so uh so there's there's
definitely within the realm that's
definitely within the realm of
possibilities and conscience-based
objections uh which might be a little
closer to which you feel uh would also
also be considered somewhat valid uh in
that context as well
they certainly should be
um and you know the funny thing is I
think the more you understand about
these particular so-called vaccines
the more obvious it becomes that you
have a fundamental right to object
right I mean to the extent that we were
told initially that oh what these do is
they introduce some mrnas into your
cells and your cells produce some
proteins and the mrnas get broken down
pretty quickly right that was [ __ ]
right they actually modified the mrnas
with what are called pseudo-eurydines
and while nature does this occasionally
they did it absolutely across the entire
mRNA which makes it incredibly durable
right this is not a natural entity at
all and my body doesn't know how to deal
with it because it has no history with
such a thing right my ability to say you
know what that's a really dumb plan
right I may regard you as clever for
inventing it but I know you're not ready
to inject that into a human being right
it's not ready for that you haven't
tested it in a way that will tell you
how that will go wrong and until you do
I want no part of it that's a perfectly
straightforward argument for me to make
that I couldn't make at the beginning of
this because the evidence that they had
done this to the mrnas was so thoroughly
buried in the Heap of garbage that they
handed us right we had to figure out
that this was going on that their story
that oh well you've got lots of mRNA in
your body and this is just another one
and it's short-lived that that was
nonsense they wanted us to believe
because it made this seem less radical
than it was so at some level what I
would say is
there are dozens of different beliefs
that one might hold
stretching from you know epistemological
considerations about how the universe
came into being straight to basic
human biology right there are dozens of
different beliefs that would support a
rational objection to taking these
things into one's body and the idea that
something has decided that it knows
better than all of those objections and
is therefore in a position to mandate
these things in spite of the fact that
you know I I keep marveling at the fact
the entire logic of the mandates is
about
the control of the pandemic but we've
known for a long time these
these transfection agents are incapable
of controlling the pandemic right so the
argument has been backed off to well
they per you know they reduce your
chances of going to the hospital or
dying which is highly debatable but the
point is that ain't their business right
that ain't their business especially for
young people who aren't in significant
risk of going to the hospital or dying
from covet in the first place and so
go ahead it's at the heart of one of our
claims uh you've gotten right to the the
the science of of one of the claims in
our cases which is that they're not
vaccines and that you know I don't know
if you're familiar with the right to die
cases that came out of Oregon and and uh
um Washington governor governor Booth
Gardner if I'm not mistaken was integral
to that fight
right and and the outcome in the Supreme
Court was ultimately that you could not
you could not force someone to take a
treatment even if it were life-saving in
other words the Supreme Court said we
don't even belong here you know but you
cannot force someone to take a
life-saving treatment and so if these
these vaccines that aren't if it turns
out they're a treatment legally speaking
that means that even if you are even if
you could show that they saved a life
and I'm with you I don't believe that's
been shown in fact I know it hasn't uh
you know that's a different issue but
um that you can't mandate a life-saving
therapy on someone under Supreme Court
precedence so if these aren't if these
are Gene therapies then you're you know
you've taken paternalism to a level now
we the the underlying premise would be
the government can controls your body
and you're getting your immune system on
a license agreement you know and so um I
mean it's something that we're we're
hoping event you know we're we're kind
of pursue majorly Place get an answer on
that question but there are there are
more than you know more than just those
questions as well I mean there's I'm
sure you followed you know relative
risks versus absolute risk they broke
the control group there's been no
well-controlled clinical studies I mean
about everything that you could possibly
do wrong in a clinical protocol has been
done wrong with respect to these
products you know every way the deck
could be stacked we have discovered that
it has been stacked and yet we do not
react with the kind of caution
that would be natural in the case that
you discover you know this many
independent uh
violations of scientific principles and
law it's absurd that we do not react uh
with shock and a great deal of
skepticism in this context which speaks
to the
um the degree of power that they have
over many people
um you know and you know Olivia and John
you have both described what are I mean
I I feel safe to say it's obvious uh
retribution that you have experienced
right the whole idea is well if you're
going to object then we're in a position
to punish you extrajudicially until you
relent which of course will cause most
people not to object in the first place
and will cause many people who do object
to relent which leaves only a tiny
number of people which actually in the
aggregate turns out to be hundreds
um to actually stand up and and stick by
it but
um
I've forgotten which one of you raised
it a few moments ago but
um
it was the issue that this is actually
functioning
uh the term vaccine is highly debatable
here but litmus test does appear to be
what is taking place and
you know again this
this reminds me of you know my
concern that what's really going on here
is we are being marched in the direction
of relinquishing the gains of Nuremberg
right if what we're going to do is
expose the entire military to a mandate
to see who objects and then we're going
to see who can be coerced into relenting
and throw everyone else out
what does that leave us with that leaves
us with a force that is effectively said
we will accept immoral orders and then
the question is what orders flow down
the chain of command after that has
happened that that to me is a very
very troubling question
I I don't I don't think you have to be
anything other than listen to the news
but there are certain politicians who've
made it clear over and over over again
they're they're fantasizing about the
notion of using the military against
their political enemies you know you
don't need a conspiracy theories you
just need to read Eric swalwell's
Twitter account I mean he's openly
talked about doing that never in my life
did I imagine I would hear a U.S
politician but I mean the
commander-in-chief has said like-minded
things and it uh you don't have to go
very far in imagining especially in
light of January 6th and there there
seems to be a I mean look the DC's had
barricades around it for how long now
they've they called out the the National
Guard and I mean we are we are heading
to a very very bad place if if we don't
if we don't turn things around but your
concerns about the military I share them
and I you know I don't have to worry
about like they do they don't the
military doesn't order me anymore but
yeah it looks to me like that's exactly
what this is headed towards is that the
ultimate goal is that you'll have a
military that will once you've bent the
knee it's really hard to stand back up
and say no that's well said
um I I find it very I you know I'm
personally
look at Joe Biden and I see a once very
competent if highly corrupt politician
who is now
um so feeble that I don't really think
he's in charge but nonetheless his
recent speech in Philadelphia
was uh conspicuous in this regard too
because what he effectively did was say
come on can't we all be unified and go
after the so-called Maga Republicans and
as much as I'm not a mega Republican
never have been don't won't become one I
was offended as an American to hear my
president singling out a group of
political opponents and effectively and
not so well veiled terms argue that they
are not entitled to basic constitutional
rights like the right to speak freely I
mean that was the implication of his
invocation of clear and present danger
in that context and so
you know again it's a matter of there
are a lot of dots in front of us and
even those of us who are cautious about
connecting them
are having an increasingly hard time
avoiding the picture that is emerging
before us and it is it is a frightening
one yeah for sure
um so before we close out here I know
there's a lot more to your story Olivia
and your story John that I think uh the
Dark Horse audience would be
um would be benefited by hearing I don't
know quite how to to get you to put this
in full context but I would like both of
you to think about what in your family
histories might be relevant here what in
your experience will bring home to the
audience of Dark Horse what is actually
taking place
uh in our military so that um you know
so the picture is is is maximally
fleshed out Olivia you want to start
sure
um so
I was always told that you know
Integrity is what you do when nobody
else is watching
um and that it's you know incredibly
hard to do the right thing what I found
throughout the this process is that
um what's harder is to do the right
thing when everyone is watching
to see the level of coercion and abuse
and discrimination that's been levied on
myself and my peers and not just within
the military but all of America and
frankly the globe has been
shocking I think that you know this is
something that every American citizen
should consider perhaps you are
absolutely pro-mandate today what if you
would were to find yourself on the other
side of a situation
my body my choice type situation that
we're dealing with right now right you
know I don't I'm not comfortable getting
this vaccine why am I being told that
this is something that's going to be
forced into my body like why why is
bodily sovereignty not protected and
furthermore you know why is there no
concern about blatant violation of
constitutional rights
I keep thinking back to I'm going to
butcher the quote but there was a a
World War II quote where you know it's
the government came for a certain group
and I did nothing they came for another
group I did nothing you know now they're
coming for me and there's no one left
if we don't stand up for constitutional
rights today and you know reach out to
our Congressman as congressmen do the
right thing and you know move forward
with the laws that are aligned with
American values the Constitution
we're going to find ourselves in a very
troubling place and I think we've seen
this historically
over and over and over again
I just hope that everyone can you know
listen to this and consider how they can
take steps to preserve our constitution
to preserve our way of life to ensure
that our children grow up to have the
same rights
like bodily sovereignty that we have had
the privilege
to have here in America
yeah I think
um that's very well said and and one of
the things that I'm hoping will come out
of this discussion is that people will
recognize
we have differences in this country
that's part of the beauty of the system
is that we hash those differences out in
a way that results in US navigating
through time better than alternative
systems
and what that means at A Moment Like
This when we're up against something so
obviously wrong as uh the Mandate of a
medically radical and unjustified
intervention to control a disease that
for most of us is far better controlled
by immunities we already have or can
easily develop
that when we're up against that and when
those mandates are being wielded against
um the very force that protects our way
of life
um that this isn't the moment for
our minor differences to matter they're
beside the point right we can talk about
our differences over how we are to
govern ourselves and where we should be
headed in the future once we have
rescued our system from whatever this
spasm of authoritarianism is but we have
to do that and so you know look I'm a
you know not even just a liberal college
professor I'm a radical college
professor sitting with members of our
military
um talking about the fate of our nation
which we all believe is jeopardized by
by moves like this so I'm hoping that
people will discover their own
patriotism and that it will cause them
to stand up in whatever role they find
themselves in whether they are members
of Congress or they are members of the
scientific Community there's certainly a
huge number of doctors who now know that
something has gone I'm desperately wrong
who have largely been completely silent
about what they are seeing
one's patriotism should cause you to say
what you know now and that doesn't mean
that there won't be consequences there
will be but the point is the consequence
for people not saying what they Now
understand to be true will be will be
even worse we are we are dependent we
are dependent on this system uh to
protect our Liberty and that means that
you know college professors should be
standing shoulder to shoulder with uh
our our men and women in uniform against
these absurd and dangerous mandates
John did you want to uh talk about more
related to your experience sure so I'll
go back all the way to my childhood real
quick and when I was a kid uh my family
was very fortunate to uh we actually
full-time RV and traveled the country
um in an RV for like five years uh and
so you know I've seen the sunrise over
Yosemite and I saw the sunset over the
Gulf of Mexico and I played in the
cornfields of Kansas and I ate a Philly
cheesesteak and checked out the Liberty
Bell and I did all of those things
without a single worry about my freedom
my ability to be who I wanted to be or
worried about uh Invasion or death or
concentration camps or anything of A
Sort that so many people in this world
are so unfortunate to experience and I
developed a love for this country I I
love this country I love what it stands
for I love the fairness that you talked
about uh and for my entire life I I
partook in that the flag behind me is
from being an eagle scout where I
learned about the values of America and
so with all that it's this desire to
stand up over this vaccine is not
because I'm a fringe right-wing
extremist or a conspiracy theorist or
some sort of religious radical I'm just
a normal American guy who loves this
country and wants to do cool things like
fly Jets and and defend my nation that
way and it's fun it's a passion of mine
and so so many service members are are
just like me in fact I'd say all of them
are just like me and that we're not
we're not crazy people we're just we're
just here to stand up for what we
believe in and we're here to represent
the very values that were instilled in
us from this great nation and so I would
encourage the American people to keep
that frame of mind when they think about
us and that we're not we've been
vilified to a large degree by by our own
government which is extremely
unfortunate in by our media and uh we're
just here to do the right thing and
that's all we care about that's that's
really what we want to do is do what's
right and do what we believe whether
that's founded in Christian beliefs or
whether it's veganism
and that's the beauty of this country is
that there's a diversity of opinion and
thought and we're allowed to express
that and share it and and we're here to
defend it as military members uh and so
you know we're kind of the boots on the
ground in this fight as unvaccinated
service members all 80 000 of us and uh
you know maybe legal and lawsuits are
going to be what takes the hill for this
for us but at the very least Congress
can be our air cover and the American
people can be our air cover you guys can
share our story you guys can even just
tweeting about it I would ask
Representatives just tweet about it it's
that easy to provide us some top cover
and help change the narrative a little
bit about who we are as people so we can
stop being villains and start being just
everyday Americans who are standing up
for what we believe in and that's really
what I'm most passionate about and why
I'm sitting here in front of this camera
talking about it just because uh the
narrative needs to change drastically if
we're ever going to see any change and
it starts in the military and it spreads
across our entire country to the rights
of even the viewers of this show
um so that's that's my plea to everybody
to Congress and the American people is
to share our story and think about us
and if you're praying person pray for us
and if you're not then maybe just think
about us but that's what we're here to
do and that's our mission and we're not
going to stop until until we win this
fight and we're setting it uh and that's
not to say we're obstinate but simply
just to mean that that we believe and we
stand firmly in what we believe
um
you're a lawyer it's kind of your job
yeah that's beautifully said John and I
will say
um you know
this isn't my first fight and one of the
things that each of the fights I've been
involved in has taught me is that you
are often led to believe that there's
some undistandable
um group on the other side
and you really have an obligation to sit
down with those folks and see whether
what you've been told is true and what I
keep finding out is no actually the
people I've been told are a threat to
the country
have a different perspective often they
often have something to teach me that I
don't know something that I missed from
the perspective that I arrived with
and in any case this has been a great
conversation in the sense that I think
it does it absolutely reveals your
humanity and I think it's going to be
hard for anybody to look at this and
portray you as villains or uh you know
crazy religious Fanatics or any of the
things that are used to get people and
this is key to get people not to listen
to what you're saying because that's how
they do it right they get people not to
listen to judge before and this is the
basis of the word prejudice right to
prejudge they get you to prejudge
somebody so you won't hear what they
have to say and then you'll believe oh
that these people actually don't care
that you know their resistance to these
so-called vaccines is causing other
people to die no that's not at all
what's going on here these are people
who believe this is the right choice
both personally and medically and that
it is completely consistent with their
love of their country and their oath to
defend the Constitution and you know
how can anybody look at that and be
indifferent right we we have an
obligation to each other is basically
the point and
um you all uh through your military
service are very directly
um addressing your sense of obligation
uh to the nation and others of us in
other roles are doing it in different
ways but really what we need to do is we
all need to stand up because
um there are many signs we are in a very
a very dangerous place
so I thank you all for joining me on
Dark Horse I thank everybody who uh is
watching this for hearing it through and
I look forward to hearing the discussion
that I know that it is going to set in
motion
is there anything any of the three of
you uh would like to say in closing
just thank you for your time this has
been fantastic and a wonderful
opportunity to engage you and your
audience thank you
um
I appreciate that you don't need to
thank me I I uh I actually really do
feel a sense of honor and privilege that
you have uh trusted me with this
discussion and I hope that it catches
the attention of people
um who will not be able to stand being
silent anymore and will stand up and
defend you
all right
thanks to all of you and uh we'll see
you next time
[Music]